anh ạ
anh alo chào các bạn ạ
anh Alo ạ
à à
ơi các bạn hãy tiêu đề hôm này rất là
dài không ạ hi vọng hôm nay à
thì các bạn sẽ theo được Chắc là nhiều
không thấy hào hứng cái chuyên mục cuối
hơn sao mày Ông đợi đến cuối buổi mày
ông ngon cũng được à
ừ ừ
ý thức ăn là mình không định nhắc đến vụ
hacking sớm Yên Thế nhưng mà
bây giờ thì mình nghĩ là
nó đang hơi bị nhận cả một tí anh Bởi vì
à các bạn đang chia sẻ Các đường link
hosting các thứ thứ ở trên cái trả lời
cái Trang Cái bồ của mình các bạn đương
nhiên là với mục đích là kiểu chia sẻ
chia sẻ về mà kiểu chữa bài rồi chia sẻ
để mà các bạn khác xem vào xem nó tiện
đấy Vân Vân Vân rất tốt không sao cả
Nhưng cái quan trọng thì nó cũng chính
là có chứa trả lời bạn này đợi tí đi cho
đến lúc tôi thấy gà cũng vừa mới vừa mới
vào trả lời là hai người trả lời rồi nó
bị Loan đấy anh thì mấy mấy cái
miếng to hơn à
anh không Chắc là do tôi khỏi ốm rồi nên
đỡ hơn đấy thì thì mấy cái này mày mấy
ông chia sẻ như thế này và đặc biệt chia
sẻ cả vụ là là người khác đăng ký Sau đó
thì hiển thị lại thông tin về đây đã
đăng ký nữa thì hoàn toàn là có thể là
các bạn có thể hack được lẫn nhau nên
cũng như là việc là có ông nào nó đang
xử với trang web hack đây lại thì ra là
mấy cái lung linh là khá nguy hiểm phải
do mình mình đang hưởng đến các bạn vẫn
chỉ đăng ký hát thôi đường link demo
được ra mình đang cân nhắc mình mình tra
hôm sau mình Sao lại không khéo mình
cũng phải mở Ờ sang bóp lên để mà chạy
mới lung linh các bạn mất
ừ ừ
ở đây Thế nên là hôm nay mình sẽ dạy các
bạn qua về việc à Có thể dễ dàng hack
được như thế nào để mà các bạn à kỷ niệm
mà không không theo kiểu như thế nữa
đúng không ạ
Ừ
thế nào bây giờ chắc là trước khi vào
buổi học về mình xin phép trả lời
Ở đây có tâm sự có tâm sự về
ẩm thực ra hôm nay tôi đang định là tôi
sẽ ngồi à
sẽ trả lời hết tất cả đống này trước sau
đó thì bảo đến Học thì học mà thôi tâm
sự đã không để để
8 giờ 8 giờ mình Bác Hồ trả lời câu hỏi
rồi học nên bỏ hôm nay cũng sẽ lại dài
thôi có thể dài nha màu một hôm trước
hiện chỉ hơn hôm nay chưa chắc là có
thời gian để mua Chữa bài tập equal nữa
cả đời thứ bảy vậy mấy ông mẹ lùi lại
tôi lịch nhá đó thứ Bảy tra chữa bài của
em à
ở đầu tiên thì hôm trước mà mình có mình
ở thời gian mình đã từng nói mình con
người mà kéo hơi bị trẻ trâu và hơi bị
gặp tao kiểu hay đi cãi nhau với những
mọi đối tượng những kiểu à
cho mọi đối tượng kiểu dạng là họ không
vì họ không có cùng suy nghĩ với mình
cho thế không ngồi nói họ ngu dốt gì cả
Ở trong đầu tôi có nhiều lúc nghĩ thì
hết kẹo không hiểu nói cái gì mà phát
ngôn những câu đấy nhưng mà Thôi coi như
ở họ không Cùng chung suy nghĩ Không
Cùng Quan Điểm với mình không ạ thì à
khi mà Mấy ông tranh luận như thế thì nó
sẽ có khái niệm mà kiểu chửi nhau cãi
nhau và phản biện
ý thì cái việc à Tại tại sao phải
mà tại sao lại phải dùng từ phản biện nó
khác với cãi nhau và cãi nhau tất cả ám
chỉ ông chàng có đôi khi chẳng có tí
lôgic thì ở cơ đôi khi ông sẽ có cái
chửi nhau trong đấy có phản biện thì sẽ
nói lôgic sẽ Google lôgic nó là gì Và
quan trọng là những cái lỗi mà các bạn
khi mà phản biện nhau đó là gì có bạn sẽ
phải trả những cái điều đấy bởi vì mình
đang thấy rất nhiều kể cả cổ điển hình
Kể cả việc vậy mấy ông đi thi Đường Lên
Đỉnh Olympia vân vân nữa tôi không Tôi
không biết thế nào tôi thì à
à À đấy tôi có không tôi Còn tôi thì
công nhận nó cũng
em không có mạng nên những kẻ người giỏi
Tôi đã từng nói đó là ờ
Ừ Tôi chỉ coi trọng những cái người mà
người ta
ở tại Đức Mạnh Toàn thôi chứ tôi không
hạn ở nề những người giỏi hơn mình nhưng
mà người ta chẳng có đức hai người ta
kiểu gì đấy thế nên là tôi không hẳn là
đánh giá cao mới ông đi đường lên đỉnh
Olympia Thôi cậu ông cứ vô địch Đường
Lên Đỉnh Olympia gặp nói cái gì cũng
được không Tôi không ngờ tôi không kiểu
dạng là thần tượng một ai đó nhưng thế
và như tôi đã nói thì những cái ông ấy
được là cũng mắc đầy những cái lỗi phản
biện kể cả khi mới chửi nhau trên mạng
Ừ thì những cái lỗi phản biện mà tối đa
định nói đó là gì đó là cấp mấy ông
thường ra hồi trước tôi có cha được cái
đấy lại từ trên nhóm ở trên Facebook thì
ra tôi thoát nhau mấy rồi vì về cơ bản
Đấy là khi nhóm này cũng mắc rất nhiều
lỗi vậy nghĩa lắm chị nhóm đấy thì ah
admin những người người amin thì là
người ra bằng rất nhiều bài hay về cái
tư duy các phản biện các thứ thứ cách
nói chuyện để mà kiểu khi mở ông tranh
luận vấn đề gì đó thì nó sẽ hiểu
sẽ nói cho nó sẽ giải quyết được cái gì
đó thay vì kiểu cãi nhau chửi nhau cho
vui đấy như thế nhưng mà thành viên
trong đấy thì không như thế Bây giờ ở cả
thành viên ông đấy nó cứ bị rát rát nên
là tôi cũng thoát đấy lỗi phản biện về
trước thì nó có lưu vụ này
U20 lỗi phản biện Hình như cái này
Ê mấy ông thử nghe qua cái này xong rồi
béo thử tự xem là mình à Hay mắc lỗi gì
nhé cái đầu tiên rất nhiều ông hay mắc
khi mà bình luận một cái gì đó
Ồ không Tôi vừa nói rồi đấy Hôm nay
không có đủ thời gian để ngồi Chữa bài
tập este đâu Cứ thử chuyển qua thứ bảy
ông ạ Cái ông Tạm nội tôi lịch cho thứ 7
nhé
ở đó là thay vì ông bà lợn là chủ đề thì
lại sỉ nhục hạ bể công kích cá người kia
đó để làm giảm câu cầu cài uy tín cái
con lời nói của họ giống như kiểu mày
làm được chưa hay là cái gì đó giống như
vừa rồi Bảo Đường Lên Đỉnh Olympia có
thứ tư đấy Cái được mày người ta không
các thứ đấy mà trong khi đó nó không bàn
chính xác về cái chủ đề đang nói là sử
là cặp đang bàn được món ăn đấy ngon Bây
giờ thì tự nhiên lại kiểu khoai là mày
Con nấu được như thế không đấy các thứ
anh không nói thế thì không ai có thể nó
lại được bởi vì ở gạo giả sử giống như
ông từng vô địch
mà xơ chết một lần nữa lại không ai được
phép cụ thể chế đồ ăn của ông bởi vì Ok
thì mấy người kia là vô địch đầu đủ ạ
Đấy thấy ra là người đó ông sẽ luôn đúng
không cái cái phần điện như thế không
thì tốt và
đấy rất nhiều người bây giờ làm kiểu thế
và nhiều người đặc biệt bây giờ làm việc
Giờ trẻ rồi còn thích grab dụng con thứ
nữa rồi nghĩ rằng grab
grab chửi nhau với ông biết rồi Thôi ra
Petr Kiểu cái gì thừa thãi kiểu sinh dục
cá nhân sau đó chị nghĩ đấy là màu chung
mà không nó sai lỗi phản biện cái đầu
tiên là luôn đúng không ạ thì ông sẽ
thấy đấy à những thành nhưng người kiểu
hả bị người khác xuống để để họ không
nói được nữa không phải là mấy hình thức
đó ông đã thắng về ra đây cái lôgic Ừ
ông chỉ hướng già là ông thiếu lôgic nên
ông đành phải chơi cho cảm lãng mạn
vì thế không thể tốt được mạnh
tiếp theo
hai tay cũng tương tự là nói điều không
tốt về người đang tranh luận đến Minh
Vân Vân nó cũng sẽ là lỗi lỗi ngụy biện
thật công ở nhân này đấy
anh nói ví dụ này đừng nhờ a phụ mày mở
tiệc vui chọn nhạc của nó tệ lắm đúng
không nhé Cứ bôi sống đưa ra một thông
tin tiêu cực
Ừ để làm giảm uy tín ạ
ở Ngụy Biện bạo lực Đó là thay vì dùng
lý lẽ hành động
nghỉ lễ lôgic thì thì sẽ kiểu đang dọa
người kia ừ ừ
anh đào là kiểu thư xếp Tại sao phải làm
thêm giờ mà không thêm phụ cấp hoặc cánh
chấp nhận làm hay là anh nghỉ việc thì
thôi đấy nghĩa âm chị sẽ dùng cái quyền
cái quyền hạn của mình cấp cái kiểu
nói chung là để mạ áp bạc người khác hay
là cậu đấy dọa người khác tâm trạng
à mà không hề mà không hề nói về cái vấn
đề hiểu về vấn đề là làm thêm giờ hay là
phụ cấp gì cả đúng không ạ ạ
cho trẻ 5 triệu mình đè ra xuống nó làm
tương tự trong cái tấn công kia mời hình
thức kiểu dạng là kiểu làm người ta như
chí người ta sẽ không tranh luận gì nữa
người ta sẽ phải tạm tuân theo bạn theo
rõ ràng và người ta có thể không phục
trong lòng không ạ
ở Ngụy Biện Bạn cũng vậy
anh cứ bị điện này anh ở đây gian lận
như ông là sai lầm như ông chưa từng
gian lận bao giờ ấy hồi đi học ông cũng
copy và suốt cái Nghĩa ăn chỉ làm được
ông ông sẽ kiểu dạng là ông sẽ không
được phán xét người khác khi mà ông đã
từng làm cái điều đấy thì cái cái phần
biện này thường ra là cũng rất nhiều mới
dính đó là kèo
đương nhiên là chúng ta cũng nên luôn có
một sự đồng cảm với cái phải với Đây á
hung thủ không phải dùng tới hung thủ
nhưng mà nói chung
đồng cảm thấy cái người mà cay gây ra
một cái hậu quả gì đó mình vẫn phải có
sự Đông ca nhưng mà không có nghĩa là
người ta đúng đúng ạ
10 nghĩa đây là đúng khi mà kiểu người
ta làm một cái gì đó sai nhiều người
cùng mắc thấy xa đấy không có nghĩa là
ngủ là người ta đúng đúng ạ ạ
thơ Nguyễn điện trượt dốc và ngụy biện
suy diễn
suy diễn này thì rất nhiều oxy lịch sử
tra là bạn nữ các bạn nữ hay suy diễn
giỏi hơn giống như kéo dạng là mình thấy
xem Tik Tok gần đây nó cũng có kiểu dạng
hả gặp
anh ơi mua cho em cái điện thoại nếu mà
không mua thì anh hết yêu em rồi Cái thứ
cái thứ kiểu nó sẽ suy diễn ra một loạt
các hướng
khi đôi khi ở đó sẽ còn Thậm chí còn
những vấn đề nghị lực lòng bé hiểu Anh
nghĩ trường hợp Hồi trước có chuyện cười
nó kiểu lạ kia ông chồng chỉ cần nói một
câu là anh nghĩ vấn đề này em giải quyết
không đúng lắm rồi xong rồi Bạn lấy Sẽ
suy diễn một loạt các kiểu
ý em nói
Ý anh nói em không nói đúng Tất cả em à
dối mà em nói dối tất cả
em con người Vân Vân Vân sau đó suy ra
kiểu anh chửi tôi là con chó Đúng không
các thứ nó bị biện kiểu suy diễn đấy
Nhìn đấy đấy cũng cậu làm cho người khác
cũng như trí người ta nói đây là cái gì
cả Cho con thêm những cái nữa giống bị
biện trắng đen này mình thấy ngoài đời
cũng gặp nhiều này
nghĩa là ờ
cho ví dụ Giả sử là kiểu bảo là
Ừ nó là cậu không Cái này thì bắt buộc
phải là cái kia ấy nghĩa là chị có hai
lựa chọn không có mua trộn một thì thì
bắt buộc phải là hay rồi thế sống như
kiểu bạn là
các bạn thích mình không là sự không thì
xe Bạn ghét mình rồi vân vân ý thế Đấy
xong rồi từ đó sẽ kiểu sẽ bị cạn lời
Không biết nói cái gì đã là một cái kiểu
ngụy biện trắng trắng đen
à mà có nghĩa vụ có nghịch điện là nghĩa
vụ chứng minh này nữa và cho mình thấy
được ra là mình đang chỉ nó qua các bạn
thôi các bạn thể đọc qua ở đây khá nhiều
này
tủ lạnh tránh chủ đề lòng vòng này
có bằng chứng vụn vặt này giống như kiểu
hút thuốc cũng rất có hại sức khỏe ông
nội mình hút nhưng vẫn khỏe mạnh có bệnh
tật gì đâu Anh ấy ăn chị ạ Dùng một cái
một cái bằng chứng rất bé thì mà đánh
giá
ở Bắc Bộ quan điểm người khác
ở ở dưới này Nói chung là đến tận 20 cái
biện và lúc còn mấy ông đọc xong ấy thì
mấy ông Trần nhận ra từ trước này mấy
ông có dính một vài cái lỗi biện này khi
cãi nhau khi tranh luận mỗi gì đó khi
nói chuyện một cái gì đó thực ra là thức
tin được mấy bộ không nhớ hết được giống
như tôi thôi Tôi thích xem hết đều ngoài
tôi không nhớ hết cho tôi sẽ tôi sẽ rất
hạn chế việc công quốc cá nhân nữa thôi
gần như bây giờ tôi không vừa cậu lên
công kích cá nhân không giống như được
kéo ra sự có có vài ông chửi tôi trên
trang cá nhân của tôi chẳng hạn Tôi
không phải trang cá nhân của họ để mà
gặp soi mói xe mà Họ sống ở đâu Họ đã
từng học gì họ từng đăng cái gì Rõ rồi
phán xét tao tưởng mày chỉ là một thằng
cậu abcs học ở trường gì gì đó khác để
công kích cá nhân
khi họ nói giúp họ nói tôi là kiểu tôi
dậy Cái gì sai thì tôi sẽ chị chú trọng
ngoài việc là cậu à
Ừ cái câu nói của họ là kiểu Họ nói tôi
sai ở chỗ nào để phân tích nó ra thôi
đấy à
khi công kích tập thể với công ty cá
nhân
em có cái cung kích cơ có cái lợi dụng
đám đông lên này Đây này
ý nghĩa là giả sử là tất cả cùng có khá
nhiều người khá nhiều người cậu ném đá
một bạn thì cũng cho rằng cả đám đông ấy
đúng và bạn kia sai cái kiểu như thế đó
là ngụy biện lợi dụng đám đông á
anh nói chung ở cái cái này thì mấy ông
trận thấy là ngoài đời được đậu mình cái
này nhiều lắm
à à
a tiếp theo và về tiêu chuẩn kép ở
các tiêu chuẩn khác thì thực ra nhiều
nhiều bạn còn không biết rằng những tiêu
chuẩn kép này là gì chứ nhờ cái này đại
khá rồi cậu Tôi nói bạn được nhưng mà
bạn không nói khẽ nói là tôi không ạ
À hôm hôm qua thì ra tôi có vào à
thế thôi có vào cái nhóm
baby
you missed speaking neutraface Nói chung
là à
Ai có bài đăng về con mèo các bạn Nếu
các bạn không biết có cái con mèo nằm im
mà máy Ly nó bị mất kê thì nhiều người
cậu thấy cậu
anh buồn bã vì nó ấn Vân tôi thì tôi
không quan tâm đến vấn đề đấy mấy người
đấy có vẻ thừa nước mắt nữa là thừa
thừa gì đó mình là tôi không có tâm em
khi họ buồn thì mình cũng đâu có quyền
phán xét họ buồn đó đúng ạ
sau đó thì có một ông và bình luận ông
này được keo trọc Ổ Kiến Lửa cái cháu
với đúng rồi cũng chết Lượn rồi ông ấy
vào bình luận
em chỉ làm con mèo thôi mà buồn bao
nhiêu hôm vào chửi tao à không phải nói
như ông bao nhiêu
có đủ thể loại phải trộn mẹ cả thế
Khi dòng họ Người ta nói kiểu bọn mày à
Mày làm sao nổi tiếng nó mày lên tất cả
và đúng kiểu công kích cá nhân giống như
tôi phải nói để Kiều có thứ
xôi kiều tự như tôi vẫn vào đỡ hộ cho mà
em một tí đó là cả đương nhiên ông này
vào
Ừ ông ấy vào nó cái câu tất cả là không
hẳn là hay lắm ở trong một cái kẹo bài
mà đáng lẽ phải buồn với nhiều người
thiếu người nói câu đấy Ở ra nó hơi cậu
hơi có thể gây chập Giận mấy bọn đấy
những về các bạn thì à
ở với người mà kiểu yêu chó mày bình
thường bình thường đi không nói cuồng
Nhưng mấy bạn kia nó không biết cuồng
thật hay không nhưng mà tôi khẳng định
được cả 90 phần trăm nữa chỉ là hơn con
số đấy mấy ông ấy không hề biết con mèo
đấy tên là gì cho đến khi có cái bài
năng đây
ý nghĩa làm chỉ ở mấy ông cầu thương hại
cho một cái con mà mình còn chưa từng
biết rõ vì nó lấy kiểu thế thì vẫn
thương ok vẫn thương rồi thường thì
thường sau đó thì kiểu bà chửi dòng họ
của thằng thằng kia lên cười ấy kêu Nếu
mà mấy ông kia nhìn một cái tổng quát
hơn thì rõ ràng mà Mấy ông nói chửi nhau
với con mèo à Mấy ông sẵn sàng chửi một
cái người mình không hề biết chỉ có dòng
họ người ta không lấy biết chỉ vì một
cái con mèo mà mình mới biết quá mạnh
Đấy đấy Cái thứ tư kĩ hơn mấy ông cũng
công nhận cũng rảnh hết
Ừ đấy thì à Nói chung là đấy 1 sự tiêu
chuẩn kép theo kiểu là mấy ông ấy bảo là
ạ Bạn này không được phép kiểu vào bình
luận kiểu như thế
soi kèo và tôi được phép chửi họ chửi
bạn đấy chứ Bạn không có khách chưa để
tôi vì tôi đúng tôi là tôi tập thể tôi
lớn hơn đông hơn đấy à
em không ở Bảo bạn đấy là vô duyên khi
mà bình luận như thế
nhưng mà Mấy ông lại vào chửi ta thì mới
ông cũng không duyên không kém đúng
không ạ
anh nói chung là tiêu chuẩn kép Nó là
kiểu ở mình là người khác thì được người
khác làm lại mình không được thế là quá
sai rồi í
10 thực là tôi Đôi khi tôi tôi biết được
cả chúng ta có thể lướt qua có những thứ
như là đôi khi tôi vẫn muốn nói vì thôi
vẫn có quan điểm đó là xã hội sẽ tốt đẹp
lợi hơn khi mà người tốt lên Điếng người
tốt đừng ra để mà đấu tranh cho cái đúng
ung thư
Ừ chứ thực ra là số lượng người tốt Tôi
không biết là số lượng người tốt hay
người xấu lớn hơn bây giờ nhưng mà chất
thả ra nếu chúng ta không lên tiếng thì
kiểu dạng khi cái xấu nó vẫn sẽ luôn còn
đói đấy Cái hình thức châm biến mấy cái
đầu một vì hồi Bé Đón xem nhiều Gặp Nhau
Cuối Tuần nữa Cái kiểu châm biếm đã từng
có thử nó là như thế
à Mà ông biết hài hài miền Bắc thường ai
châm biếm ở Hải pháo kéo tôi sẽ đến lưu
vào những thế thói hư tật xấu của xã hội
để mà để mà kiểu người khác có thể thấy
buồn cười như họ sẽ nhìn lại được đó là
cuộc sống sẽ có những cái kiểu như kia
một người ta sẽ tránh tránh mắc lại
những cái đấy nữa
Ừ rồi nói nốt cái cuối một phút chính
phủ nói đó về tiền bạc
quan điểm của mình giống như là mình đã
từng nói là mình làm cái cái ngày miễn
phí và vì sao vẫn miễn phí sao mình cũng
không định
Ý mình là làm nhiều cái sợ miễn phí chia
sẻ các thứ thứ
anh
được như là niềm mà đi làm Bây giờ mà là
miễn phí nốt thì chắc à
Không có gì bộ mồm Ăn được ạ Mình thức
từng nghĩ khá nhiều về cái tiền bạc rồi
anh ra tiền thì không thể bỏ đi giống
như thời bao cấp và bỏ tiền đi rồi cùng
thì chẳng ai chịu làm cái gì cả
Ừ ai cũng như nhau thì chẳng ai làm gì
cả đâu Nếu bắt buộc phải có thêm một cái
gì đó yếu tố để các bạn phải có phải
phải làm để mà có cái Man Ít nhất là như
thế
các bạn thử nên là không thể phủ nhận
được sự quan trọng của đồng tiền nhưng
mà
cho mình luôn cho cái đồng tiền nó luôn
ở mức thuế cùng trong cái việc à mình
quyết định một cái vấn đề gì đó Mai mà
may mà đến giờ mình vẫn chưa nghèo đói
Hay cậu thiếu thốn gì cả Bởi vì hồi mẹ
từ bé
đi tìm nhưng mà mình không phải trong
con
Con Nhà Giàu đi nhổ nhuộm bạn thôi rất
nhiều ông bạn đừng chơi từng mới gặp tôi
sẽ nghĩ tôi làm con kiểu công tử bột thì
tôi được
Ừ tôi da trắng rồi bảo chồng gây có nhôm
chẳng làm mấy cái việc gì cả đường thế
là nhìn thôi được Chắc hai công tử bột
thứ
Ừ nhưng mà không Nhà tôi thế là tôi là
không có nhà Thế bây giờ không ở nhà thờ
gia đình khá hoàn cảnh cả là
bố mẹ thì cái này đang hơi Cá nhân tí
nhưng mà bắt buộc phải có cá nhân Hôm
nay thì mới nói được cái nguồn gốc của
cái cái này cái tiền định nghĩa tiền ở
trong quan điểm của tôi Đó là kiểu
cho bố mẹ thì cả hai gia đình ruồng bỏ
Ừ thế là kiểu ở gầm cầu kiểu nói chung
là sóng
ở đấy cũng vài tháng này vậy Bán hết mọi
thứ quần áo để mà kiếm tiền ăn cá thứ
sau đó mãi về sau thì mới được à
Về ở ở nhà ngoại thì với điều kiện là
phải chia tay Bố đã đấy đi Nói chung nhà
sau đó thì kiểu
em ở luôn với ông bà ngoại từ đó đến đến
bây giờ
gia đình tôi thế
Ừ thế là từ trước này không ở nhà sau đó
thì mẹ tôi làm gì Mẹ có bán vào nước
Thôi mẹ tao bán hàng nước rồi sống qua
ngày bán nhà nước bù đêm thực đêm để bán
hàng có thứ sẽ không hề có sự khá giả
thì đây cả À
vợ chồng ở nhà mình ở phố cổ cái mác này
vẫn có vẻ nhe Bây giờ ở ai nhưng mà đây
cũng chẳng phải nhà của mình nói chúng
mình ở là
đó không phải nhà của mình thì ra là
mình kiểu cổ Đấy mình chẳng có cái tiếng
nói gì cả Mình gọi là sống nhờ mà nó
không ạ Và cái nhà đấy thì ông bà con
chia 7 người con nữa Có gì đấy là tội
chẳng hi vọng và thở ra từ trước Mai à
đấy nữa vì 7 người con nhưng mà các bác
của tôi thì nó là một cái gì đó kêu rất
là ờ
à rất là tiền bạc
thế cửa là
vẫn còn tranh giành cái nhà đấy thư gửi
các Bác đều có nhà riêng rồi đều dầu để
có tận hai ba nhà biệt thự như vẫn trên
này cả nhà của ông bà không đuổi mẹ con
tôi ra ngoài cơ
A và Nhưng mà thế mà vẫn không chịu nuôi
ông bà vẫn để mẹ tôi nuôi ông bà cơ đấy
7 người ngon nhé
em lấy lấy lấy nhà cũng vài trăm của ông
bà cơ về các thứ vỡ không đưa ông bà con
Thư nói chung là rất nhiều thứ liên quan
đến tiền bạc
May mà mẹ tôi vẫn đủ nuôi sống thôi
Ừ để mà tôi vẫn nó học ăn học thì được
như bây giờ thế là tôi rất kỹ việc
Ừ nhất định danh bạ
khi tôi cảm thấy tiền bạc nó làm ảnh
hưởng cuộc sống của tôi nghe từ hộp bé
nghe từ lúc trước khi chào đời cho đến
kiểu đến khiến gia đình tôi khổ như thế
các thứ Nên là tôi về sau sẽ không tự
nhiên là mình sẽ phải cố gắng đủ giỏi để
mà
thì mình sẽ không bao giờ phải kiểu
vướng nói chuyện này nữa
Ừ nhưng mà à
À mà đấy là tôi sẽ không Không làm gì đó
thì tưởng quan tâm mình cái tìm bạn lắm
ở trên mạng ai mà chơi với tôi quen tôi
thì sẽ thấy tôi rất thoải mái trong việc
về tiền bạc không được tính toán
à à
Đó là kiểu thử ta là tình bạc cũng nó sẽ
làm ảnh hưởng tình cảm rất nhiều trong
các mối quan hệ nó vốn luân chuyển một
công cụ thôi nó không thể thiếu nhưng nó
vẫn chỉ một công cụ thôi
Ừ ok hơi bị tâm sự hơi bị ỉa chảy quá
rồi Ừ thôi bắt đầu buổi họp nha em
à
Vì sao anh định nghỉ làm để làm bị lag
full ham không à
Anh không nghỉ làm thì cho hết cái màn
rồi anh sẽ không đi làm được mà như tôi
và nói về sau giả sử thuộc về họ trả Vì
sao tôi cũng thấy con định làm vlog vài
cái nữa nhưng mà chắc là không để kiếm
tiền thì
đi làm cũng trẻ vì đam mê thôi
Ừ
nhưng mà chắc là cũng xe ra đều đều
a tiếp theo
cái hình như mình nhớ không làm được
Hình như bạn lấy hỏi câu này liên quan
đến cái lúc mà mình đang chia sẻ cái ứng
dụng ích khí xe rác Cái hôm trước mình
nó cái ứng dụng mà kẹo khi mà
một cái gì đó chạy thì lập tức là cái
sau sẽ được sẽ có một cái kích hoạt cái
cơ đúng không ạ sẽ được kích hoạt bạn
hiểu họa Instagram ứng dụng này các bạn
Tải ứng dụng này trên có thể
khi dùng trên này Nhưng mà thường là tôi
thấy ngon hơn ở trên áo thì à
Ê mày không tải ứng dụng máy về thôi mấy
ông chén giả là vào kết nối đến các bạn
các tài khoản mạng xã hội của mình sau
đó bây giờ sự có rất nhiều cái hay giống
như kiểu
cậu dạng là cầu bang mới gì đó lập tức à
đẩy lên vít hát hay để dysport chẳng hạn
luôn vẫn đấy cũng có một cái và cái này
là nó lưu lại trên server nó để chạy
chạy ngầm hộ các bạn thế nên là nó không
tốn cho bộ nhớ các bạn cho tốn cái gì cả
cùng lắm thì như tôi đã nói đó là miễn
phí gì sẽ là sẽ Hình như chỉ cài được 12
cái
không thể cài bao nhiêu cái cũng được
con mất phí sẽ thoải mái hơn
Vì thế nên là mấy ông mất một tiền thôi
à à
Ừ anh không lên 11 à trái ý ông ấy nói
là Windows 11 tất cả tôi hiện tại thầy
Windows 11 chẳng hơn Windows 10 ở ở giao
diện thì ra là tôi đợi nó lên hẳn có một
cách tính năng gì đó đáng để lên và công
và cũng là
để cho nó ổn định đã Tôi thấy vẫn chưa
ổn định thôi Lên làm gì đúng ạ nhiều hôm
lên còn muốn xuống mà
à À cái bạn ấy hỏi như này ăn thịt lại
cái khóa này mình có dậy kịp để mà các
bạn Vừa làm đoán 20
à à
ờ ờ Theo mình là kịp một vì là mình sẽ
Phượng ngay ngay tại thời điểm này các
bạn cũng đang hình dung được như mình
nói thậm chí các bạn đang nghĩ làm trước
các giao diện các hư hư nghĩ đề tài có
từ rồi sau đó gì sau những buổi này thì
các bạn thành dâu được ví dụ hộ sau bổ
này không làm được xem thêm sửa xóa rồi
thì mới ông chỉ đội tôi
em dậy thiết kế mày ông lên datapes sau
đó thì mới ông
bắt đầu làm đầy đủ tính năng xem thêm
sửa xóa hộ tất cả các bạn Đấy là tương
đối gần như xong được Cái trang web đoán
một rồi bị đón một nửa ra nó chị Chung
quy quanh còn lại mỗi xem thêm sửa xóa
thôi nó không có gì cả cái
cho nên là
23 tháng với mình khá thoải mái
cho thoải mái từ cho cả những kẻ bạn mà
kiểu à Đang đi làm con Thư đương nhiên
là
các bạn mới học thì 23 tháng nó sẽ là
tương đối không hẳn không hẳn là
tin nhắn cũng không hoa nở dày mình thấy
thế
a tiếp theo là có bạn thì cho biết Pu
epo video là kiểu dạng như cũng là một
cái cách kết nối mẹ mai quý out theo
kiểu hướng đối tượng thay vì dùng cái Hà
máy quay Hôm trước mình nó dụng nếu mà
bạn nào biết về cái này rồi thì các bạn
vẫn áp dụng được nhé Không sao cả nhưng
mà tôi chỉ cho nếu không làm ngay thôi
chứ mày ông không làm hướng đối tượng
hoàn toàn hay mới với xe đâu nhé
tiếp theo nữa đó là Chào bạn hôm trước
bình luận cái này cái này không phải một
câu hỏi
vì vậy chỉ một câu cảm thán thôi đó là
TP mà nhúng thêm một đống hlcs với cả
loa Speed nữa trong một cái file rồi sẽ
là tập Nham Đúng thế nên là buổi sau tôi
sẽ hướng dẫn các bạn là sẽ là phải tách
tách các thứ thứ ra thì ông sẽ thấy da
tôi sẽ hướng dẫn bé không tách dần ra để
cho một cái file của ông không quá dài
về một file nó dài mà đôi khi nó còn lặp
lại nữa đó lặp lại khá nhiều nên mấy ông
sẽ thấy à
ở Cốt nó dài ra thì khó sửa tính nhân là
như thế trước mắt là như thế đã trông ạ
Anh
a tiếp theo
ờ ờ nhưng vừa nãy mình nói Đăng cốt lên
hosting thì thứ nhất là
vì nó có thể dễ bị hack rồi các bạn vẫn
chưa lường trước được tất cả những cái
những cái kiểu chống Thế là có thể ông
nào đó vào hack của mấy ông thì những
cái ông bà tiếp theo thì sẽ là bị hack
không ạ thấy ra tôi khuyên mà em không
không nên băng hosting đường lên host
sinh nữa mà chỉ nên đăng ít áp thôi tôi
vẫn đọc được cốt mà Tạm thời trước mắt
được tôi vẫn nằm ở cốt a đấy tiện thể
nói luôn à
trình kia ông đang học sinh nên tôi
không xem được cốt PT của mấy ông nên là
mấy ông nên phải đăng ký tên Linh kết
hợp cũng như là thực ra tôi chấm mấy ông
thì tốt chỉ xem được mức tương đối thôi
Thông cảm
Ê mấy ông bây giờ Đông sinh viên tôi
cũng lại chấm cách định vị trong bé ông
được
Ê bà Nè thấy tôi dùng từ nhạy cảm đây
nữa nó là gì bởi vì là vừa rồi Tôi để ý
nghĩa là có phải ông copy code từ bên
hosting đấy sang bên get help vẫn còn
vẫn còn là user name và password của cái
bên hosting Thành A đấy một cái nghệ ca
đương nhiên là ông sẽ nghĩ rằng là khắc
tinh của ông chẳng có gì cả nên là bị
hack vào cũng chẳng sao cả Nhưng mà việc
mong béo để lộ mật khẩu đôi khi là mật
khẩu nhiều ông dùng một mật khẩu cho tất
cả mọi số 4 đã được họ vẫn là mỗi thứ
tình cảm đúng không ạ Cháu là mấy ông
Khi mà Tự ra tội từng bị dính một lần đó
là khi mật copy luôn Đúng cái cốt ở trên
local thôi đẩy lên khí H2 nha bị lỗi rất
nhiều cái cảm ở trong cái cốt đấy với
ông phải cân nhắc lại vụ đấy Đó là mấy
ông
em xem kỹ lại cái file khi mình đẩy lên
nó có liên quan mật khẩu liên quan đến
tóc nad ngoan Cookie hay các thứ không
trước khi ông đẩy lên ký Tháp nhá ghế
Tháp nó nơi công cộng mà đúng không ạ
ừ ừ
Ừ Ok tôi vừa trả lời xong hết rồi ông ạ
Bây giờ bắt đầu học nhé
khi bắt đầu buổi học thôi hôm nay sẽ học
khá nhiều đấy
à à
ừ ừ
Anh tên hình mình cứ mở thời trang mạng
khi nóng tính school này Ừ thì nó sẽ ra
được bài như này không ạ
Hôm trước mẹ làm những gì hôm trước mình
đã hiển thị cho toàn bộ những cái bài
răng thêm được bài mới như thế này không
ạ Và ấn vào xem chi tiết được một bài
đăng rồi Hôm nay mình làm tính năng sửa
xóa trước mắt là sự Xóa ngọn thì mình sẽ
ra ạ mình vào lại cái file crack tải lại
file trang chủ ở Đông ạ Mình sẽ ra thêm
thường người ta sẽ thêm cái nút sữa vào
nút xóa ngay bên cạnh từng bài đăng như
này chị sẽ cái kiểu ý này sữa non rồi
xóa này à
ở VTC
tại sẽ là
mình bạn chắc cái này sẽ là for update
thừa nhận chuẩn PJ và
Em hãy nêu ra vào
đây người ta sẽ hiểu là khi bấm mà sửa
đây nó sẽ sửa cái bài đăng bài đăng này
không phải sự bé đang này đúng không ạ
thì giống như hôm trước mình làm cái vụ
xem thôi Có mình nên truyền mã vào trong
cái đừng đừng Linh khi bấm vào mình sẽ
hiểu là mình sửa cái bài đăng nào nó sẽ
như này lại bấm vào đây sẽ sửa đúng ạ
đấy
a tiếp theo là vĩnh copy tên file Thôi
đi file mới đây
tìm lồ này tôi thường hay làm như thế
này không biết mấy ông như nào Nhưng tôi
thường làm này nhanh nhỉ
ở tại xóa này
Anh vừa mới tạo nhiều hoặc 18 xóa đi Ừ
thôi thường này đắp ý kết trình Cài file
in shop này lên Tại sao có gì Rõ ràng là
Ford rất là giống nhau để tôi thường này
đã ký kết trình Cái pha lê này đó để
chúng ta đã có phai mới là tiện đúng
không ạ Nếu mà sau vai tách của mấy ông
thì không có mấy cái thêm tùy chỉnh kể
topic kết các tư thế này đâu nếu không
phải cày nên kẹp moggi à Cái Pocket
giống tôi nhá Pocket của tôi ở trên
trang blog tôi có đấy
đó và bây giờ đương nhiên là khi mình
sửa cái gì đó tốt làm chị mình cần hiển
thị lại toàn bộ những cái nội dung đã có
đúng không vì mình sửa chứ không phải
mình gõ lại từ đầu đúng không ạ thì cái
để mà lấy lại toàn bộ nội dung đã có thì
mình sẽ dựa theo cái mã này mình đã kết
nối cơ sở liệu sai bây giờ theo mã này
lấy đúng cái bài đăng này về để mình
điền đầy đủ toàn bộ thông tin lại và bài
đang đấy vào trong này để mình sửa đúng
Ừ thì đây sẽ là
đoạn này mình cũng có có thể copy được
tiếc mình lại copy đoạn trên này thôi
mình có vui đoạn trên này à
ông
bà bây giờ mình sẽ là lại mã đôla ghế Mã
Ý
a selected for tin tức này Where mã bằng
mã ngay các kết quả trả về các kết quả
này như hôm trước mình có nói cái vụ mà
xem cụ thể một bài đăng cũng tương tự
với đó là khi mà mình lấy cái này về Rõ
là các bạn sẽ nghĩ rằng chỉ có một bài
bài báo có cái mã thì thôi đúng không ạ
nhưng nó vẫn sẽ trả về dạng mà mình cảm
thấy thằng đầu tiên của mà sẽ là kiểu ý
kiến thức lúa
bằng Michael cách dây
kết quả à
Anh
ấn Window số
thì mũi tên để sẽ chia đều được như thế
Em hãy kiện
ừ ừ
anh ở đây sẽ ra tự động điền vào trước
thì nó sẽ có vô lu như thế này thì sẽ
tin tức này
để tiêu đề ê
Ê bà cái value trước cho cái thằng cách
Alo này thì mình sẽ không có mình sẽ
thích thẳng ở đây chứ mình không có cái
tục tình boro giống như thằng này nhé
này mới ông xem này họ như này ở đây sẽ
nội dung này
ở đó Ok chưa
a tiếp theo Linh ảnh Peru thôi
À
mà đây đội đó là
sữa ạ
Có ai như này
ờ ờ
a tiếp theo làm Nếu mà Mấy ông Thực ra
là bấm sửa như thế này
Ừ thứ nhất là phải sửa cái này thì vô xe
tắt nết này
thế theo nữa đó là khi vào xưởng này
mình đẩy cái form này sang
[âm nhạc]
7 file này for mày sang cuốn sách update
thì nó không đẩy được cái mã này sang
theo đâu rồi Cái cái mã bằng 6 đây này
Nó sẽ không được đẩy theo ở trong cái
pho mày đâu thì nó sẽ bị mất hay tôi thử
ví dụ cho mèo nhé á
cách tạo phải mới này
FPT này
tôi thử này mỗi Đô La Mã về đôla ghét mã
người uống xe nữa nhé
tả lại trang đã này phẩm sữa này đó với
ông thế là mã không có này tôi đổi nó
thành đô reports để lấy mã về tả lại tra
này vẫn không được đúng ạ đấy bởi vì họ
cái mã Đấy nó đang ở trên hai nghệ sĩ nó
không về được đẩy theo phải phom tôi bấm
nhầm mất rồi
em thì làm thế nào để món đẩy theo được
cả cái fan Bây giờ thì chị thì mình sẽ
phải mình sẽ có tôi thấy à thường hay sẽ
có 2 cách
số 1 là ông sẽ có một cái input ở đây
như này và nêm Sẽ Làm mã xong rồi va lu
nó là như thế này là sự Đô La Mã nhé các
bạn
thì tại sao này nếu không thấy có một
cái phút đây đúng không ạ sau khi tôi
bấm vào thì đương nhiên là cái cái này
nó sẽ được gửi theo rồi là sự tôi nào ra
này
đó nếu không thấy nó ra không ạ Chứ
không bé Ông thấy thử cái cái in phút
như này nó hiển thị ra như người dùng sẽ
không hiểu vì dùng có quan tâm mã bằng
bao nhiêu đâu đúng không ạ người dùng
Điền vừa Vũ Cẩn ơi có khi cầm cái lỗi
không ạ nên Cường cái một là cái bút này
sẽ bị ẩn đi nó là hai đứa như này
thứ hai là hai bên sẽ ẩn đi ăn đi Ở đây
em chỉ ẩn đi người dùng không nhìn thấy
chứ có ông Ấn cân cho nó ngủ lâu nữa sẽ
thấy là như thế này và tôi thấy khá
nhiều trạng trang thật trước tựa thằng
Facebook nó cũng làm theo cơ chế kiểu
như này nó sẽ là ẩn nó đi
ở đây là một cách khoảng cách thứ hai là
mấy ông truyền thẳng lên ở trong cái á
trên lý này là hỏi chấm mã bằng như vừa
nãy và mình sẽ dùng riêng cái mã thì
mình sẽ dùng đôla ghét để lấy mã về có
những cái thằng khác rồi mình cùng Dora
post Nhưng mà thường là tôi thấy à mày
nhiều thằng Hướng là làm theo cậu hứng
này có hơn nên tôi sẽ dậy mấy ông theo
hướng này nhá Ừ
Ừ
ok Tại mình sẽ có tiêu đề bằng đôla post
chủ đề không ạ
nội dung và anh
anh
ở đây ạ ở mỗi buổi tôi sẽ nói thêm bằng
những cái mẹo nữa này mà ông rút gọn cốt
này đó là mấy ông thấy là thôi lại phải
lặp lại cái đoạn điệp khúc này đông ạ
đoạn này còn khuyên đóng kết nối này đấy
nhưng mấy ông hiểu nó lúc nào phải lặp
lại lặp đi lặp lại cái đoạn cốt này và
việc lặp đi lặp lại cốt ở trong lập
trình Nếu không có được tốt Bởi vì
bởi vì là nó liên quan việc ở Giả sử về
sau ông muốn đổi đã tao bây giờ sao cũng
không còn gì school nữa Hoặc do ông đổi
mật khẩu thì sao Đúng không ông lại phải
sửa mọi pha nhắc đến cái loại cốc đấy
thì ra đấy không người tốt cốt lặp đi
lặp lại đến 2 lần ở miếu phải cân nhắc
việc là phải tấm nó sang một cái file
khác rồi mày ông chen cái pha này vào Ừ
nó là sẽ làm như sau tôi sẽ tạo ra một
cái file ở đây tôi lỡ để toàn bộ Cái này
tiếng Anh với tôi đề này tiếng Anh lúc
nhá phải thì con wreck.it này phải này
nó bản chất là gì phải là chỉ có mỗi hai
dòng cốc thôi Nó là cái này đó như thế
này sau đó thì
tất cả cái đoạn này của tôi
khi sử dụng cốt ở đoạn này thì tôi sẽ
ghi là include
I
Connect sample
cái Hà Min Plus này nó có tác dụng là
chèn thêm cái file khác vào và vẫn dùng
được bình thường nếu khai báo biến kết
nối ở đây thì dưới này dùng được biên
kết nối để luôn không thấy là nói cái
các bạn Nếu thấy chẳng Cốt nó chẳng thay
đổi gì cả Không ạ Nó vẫn sẽ chạy như thế
nhưng mà
Mấy ông về sau mấy ông sẽ chị sửa ở chỗ
này thôi tất cả chỗ khác gọi để cái file
này đều được Tại tôi sẽ sửa nha nhiều
với ông tôi sẽ sửa nó bên file này cũng
thế đội đây này phải thật ngay đội đây
này đó nếu không thấy nó sẽ ngắn hơn khá
nhiều không ạ Và đây tôi chỉ chén hết
đứa này thế này xong rồi ông ạ ạ
à à Nhân tiện đây thôi chị mày ông luôn
nhân nhân tiện nói với cái in Plus này
để cho chị mèo luôn nhé
đang là file for update đúng không Ok
mày không Thấy ok Đang last bình thường
đúng không ạ hả Mình cứ nút đang loa rất
là bình thường là xưa gọi là nếu ra sự
méo in Plus cái file này về sau file này
tự nhiên có vấn đề phải bị mất hay là
thậm chí ông gõ đường link những cách
pha này lỗi là sự đừng lên lỗi như này
trở lại đúng không ạ
Thấy thì khi mà in close ngay Rất là nó
tìm đến cái file có file của tên như thế
này và Trần pha này hiện tại đã không
tồn tại đúng không ạ thì nó sẽ xảy ra
trường hợp Duy tự nhiên nó sẽ xin lỗi
thôi nó sẽ thì cái lỗ ở đây cái sẵn rồi
nhưng mà ông thấy à ngoài việc nói gì
thì lỗi là file này không tồn tại này
đúng không ạ Nó còn hiển thị ra mua loa
lỗi ở dưới này nữa như thế này Tại sao
tới nạn thôi bởi vì mấy ông dùng cốt ở
trong Ừ thì nó chạy mà đúng không ạ thì
cốt ở trong vai này không còn thiếu như
toàn bộ cái phân dưới lỗi vẫn là đấy
thôi đúng không ạ
liên hệ để tránh việc mà khi vào chèn
cái file nào đó lỗi mà dưới nó vẫn chạy
như này thì không tốt à không không ở
lại không cần đổi trái các đâu mình sẽ
khái niệm mà request như thế này
anh
đi quay nó sẽ cũng sẽ là ingrowth tất cả
là sẽ chèn thêm cái file khác vào như là
các bạn xem thử nhé
ở đó
Ừ cái dùng đi quay như này các bạn sẽ
thấy ra khi mở file không tồn tại
Ừ thì cốt ở dưới nó không chạy luôn đấy
con khi mà file tồn tại thì các bạn hãy
nói như nhau với qua anh Club rồi như
nhau đều trả hiện kết quả như nhau đúng
ạ đấy
xem thêm tất cả những cái file quan
trọng theo theo theo như tôi vừa nói vì
những file quan trọng thì có bạn nên
dùng đi qua chứ không nên dùng yêu cút
về mà chèn thêm cái phao Và thậm chí về
sau các bạn sẽ còn biết thêm được nhưng
mà cốt các bạn dài quá Này nói thêm một
tí này là các bạn sẽ thêm Cậu biết cả
was once này nữa nếu không biết tiếng
anh một tí thì biết ngoan này tức là một
lần đấy thì kệ cái j quone nó chỉ đơn
giản và khi quay thì chèn file One cũng
sẽ ở trẻ nếu file nhưng chỉ một lần bạn
thắc mắc thì thấy cái này giúp cổ truyền
nhiều lần á Không nhưng mà cái này có
tác dụng là nó hiện chén bao nhiêu lần
cũng được tôi như thế này thì sẽ làm chỉ
là nó sẽ chèn lên file này lần này lần
tự nhiên và các bạn cốt này thì nó không
sao chứ Giờ xưởng với các bạn cốt mà để
in ra một cái gì đó các bạn
Ừ thì các bạn thấy nó lặp đi lặp lại nó
sẽ tạo là bao nhiêu cái đít rồi đây bao
nhiêu cái gì gì đó nhiều lần
freeone thì nó sẽ nó sẽ chèn file này
một lần thôi lần sau gọi đến file đấy
nữa vẫn vẫn là file cũ ý thì nó sẽ không
trả thêm nữa
Ừ để tác dụng của cái Hàn đi quay One E8
trẻ nó chị tiện cho lập trình viên để
lập trình viên mà kẹo có quên là đã chèn
file đấy ở đoạn trên này rồi thì nó sẽ
không cần phải chèn thêm nữa
Lê Quốc Khánh có lợi cho lập trình viên
rồi kìa bởi vì tại sao phải xin hàng này
bởi vì sau tôi các bạn Nhớ lúc đầu tôi
nói qua về cái vụ à à
ở tay
ừ ừ
ờ ờ
ở đây đây pp nhúng lẫn lộn với các thứ
làm nó rối mấy ông nhớ tôi bảo là cái
cốt về sau bọn mày ông có lên đấy nhìn
dòng ạ thì mấy ông sẽ tách nhỏ thành
nhiều file để mấy ông Wei lại Linh Plus
như này nhiều lần đấy đâu ạ thì cái việc
anh về sau gần như là một file của ông
Toàn đi khoai cái Plus xong rồi mấy ông
sẽ có trường hợp việc cái file Giả sử
cái file con ếch này còn J quite mình
cái file khác vào file khác đấy cũng vui
quay file con ếch thời gian mới bị lặp
đi lặp lại cái file con ếch hai lần để ạ
đấy
chỉ có một vài trường hợp để tôi nói cái
file này lặp lại thì không sao nhưng có
những cái file khác gặp lại nó sẽ lỗi
đúng không ạ Cái thành gian làm mấy ông
sẽ phải thêm cái Hà mày để chắc chắn nó
sẽ chỉ được gọi đến một lần thôi ấy
Ê mấy ông để nó cẩn thận thì béo không
dùng hàm ý một nốt Không dùng hàm vinh
Wei mới ông chỉ dùng hàm viqua ăn cũng
được cho là chắc Ừ thế là tốt nhất trong
ạ ạ
à à
I - hàm phải này lại gọi đến file kia xô
xe kia lại gọi file này liên tục Chắc là
nó hình để quên mất đúng không ạ là đẹp
lại bao nhiêu lần thì chết luôn không ạ
cái lý do phải có sinh ra cái hay one
ok hơi dài dòng quá lại quay lại em nhé
Ok
câu truy vấn đây khi đoàn đấy
bằng
update tin tức đúng không ạ
xét thôi Thấy viết thì cậu này không
biết mày ông tôi tôi sẽ viết cũng nhanh
nha mấy ông thử xem nhé Mình cập nhật
tiêu đề rồi đúng không ạ Chị sẽ đưa tiêu
đề này
nội dung này ảnh này anh mãi
khi
về sẽ là
nội dung này à
hình ảnh quê mã bằng mã đó
à à
à à à à
ở đây đây đây các bạn sẽ thế cập nhật
tiêu đề nội dung ảnh whey mã bằng ngày
mã mình truyền lên Thế xong lúc ạ Mày có
đi free
cái nối này
câu truy vấn ạ
ở đây vẫn phải đóng Lúa
hay quên cái vụ này
à à
Vì
vậy tôi thử độ nhé F1 này ngày 31 này
ở đây
anh Linh ảnh để tra tại Nguyên đi uống
sữa này
cô gái không không lỗi gì cả không báo
lỗi gì cả đúng ạ
300 lỗi bởi vì rõ ràng là tôi có in a
lỗi đâu đúng ạ bây giờ kìa cả câu truy
vấn của tôi lỗi như nào nữa cũng không
yên lỗi nhưng mà Mấy ông cách tốt nhất
là một lần mấy ông vào đây B để xem hay
là mấy ông cứ mở hẳn một cái trang trang
chủ Để mà xem trước không ạ đó mấy ông
sẽ thấy là cái một lên đây rồi ở trong
mẹ đúng rồi đúng không ạ Ok Thế được rồi
à à
ở đó tiếp theo là đừng cái xóa xóa Thì
nó khá nhanh đây có chuyện ra là truyền
nó không cần có một cái form gì cả Nói
chuyện lạ Delete Thôi như thế này cũng
sẽ truyền cái mã của cái bài Mình cần
xóa lên sau đó thì mình bấm mà ở sẽ xóa
thôi
ở bài nó sẽ bấm vào nha sẽ hiểu là xóa
cái bài đăng đấy đứng như là thường ở
mấy cũng làm cẩn thận thì mấy ông lên
thêm một cái copper một cái xác nhận nữa
không ạ
từ
[âm nhạc]
ngày 31 à Tôi không hiểu sao nó thay
ngày mưa nhớ hơi sai đấy
à mà không ngày 31 là bên nội dung hỏi
về nội dung
tiêu đề rồi mới sửa cái F1 thôi à
ờ ờ
ở
đây tôi sẽ tạo 1 file nữa là phải xóa
cái tên
sẽ mình sẽ lấy mã về
khi quay đến cái kết nối
con ếch chứ
cái để anh ở việc đôi khi bị cũng không
nhớ rồi lúc nào tiếng Anh tiếng Việt thì
ra tôi cốt khi ở trên công ty Cô ơi cốt
Toàn Toàn bộ bằng tiếng Anh Rồi nghe Huế
phải là đáng sợ nó quá nhưng mấy ông
Thực ra cũng đơn giản lắm Bởi vì à Nếu
mấy ông mới vào công ty ra người ta cũng
có cốt mẫu có thứ Nếu chỉ xe biến là
người bạt ở gì đặt giống thế là được rồi
khi em Nếu không hiểu Nó nghĩa là gì là
được
Ở
đây câu truy vấn
thông tin tức
que mã bằng mã thế xong
uống rất thích cái xóa với nó là dang
tay ngắn nhất là khốn nạn nhất à
em bận mà Soái
à Không có gì xảy ra đi quay lại bên này
Anh quay Nếu mà Mấy ông bấm quay lại như
này ông sẽ thấy không bị xóa đâu vì quay
lại cái này hình như nó lưu lại vì vậy
em với ông tải lại chan thì mới thấy bị
xóa nhá
Em đang học cơ bản không dùng phương
trình không dùng các thứ không dùng thư
viện từ đâu đơn thuần hết mà à
Ừ ok đấy đấy đầy đủ tính năng thêm sữa
xóa xem thêm sữa Xóa Bây giờ mình sẽ làm
thêm những cái gì à Nếu mà Bộ mày Chị
nhắn thì thôi như cả nó hơi bị ngàn quá
thế nên là mình sẽ dạy theo các bạn thứ
nhất là vì à phận tìm kiếm trước đi tìm
kiếm đã mình sẽ có thêm một cái hai
người thế này ta sử mình có nhiều bài
đăng không ạ bây giờ cách tốt nhất của
mình làm mình sẽ có
D3 Mày đang đi
thì mình sẽ thêm ba bà nhé Dân Trí đây
kiếm 3 bài đã thêm hai bài nữa được
à à
Vì sao làm tính năng cậu
khu dân trí đang bài gì thì mình sẽ tự
động lấy bày lại bài đấy về trang web
của mình không có một cách
à à
các bạn hôm trước vậy
ta0 ảnh trông có vẻ vẫn thế như không
à à
AE nhập copy Emax press Ok rồi
du lịch Nguyễn cay nghiệt ở
à à
Ừ nếu nhớ tiêm vắcxin đi nhé ạ
em lấy được mà
Thì
bà gọi đến cái link này là xem được Bà
Đanh nó thì sẽ có 1 con Boss này đọc bài
đấy hộ bà thôi lấy hết toàn bộ những
thông tin của bé đang ấy về Thế có nhớ
xong Thế ông đã gần như Clo được một cái
trang web người ta về chúng tôi có hai
ba để xem nên không thôi
Ừ ok Nói chung có 3 bài tại sao tự nhiên
tôi có 3 bài Bởi thứ nhất là tôi sẽ làm
việc tìm kiếm Thứ hai là tí làm phân
trang 3 bài thuốc giả sự phân mỗi bài 1
trang cũng được chẳng hạn thế
ở đây là sử dụng bây giờ mình sẽ có cái
thanh tìm kiếm ở trên này đúng ạ Mình
nhập vào để tìm kiếm thì tôi thường hay
chơi như này sẽ có một cái thẻ cáp chân
này Tại sao có thể phát sinh bởi vì nó
sẽ nhìn vào cái trên trên của cái thuê
buồn đó giữa khá thích nó thế heo mình
sẽ có bao nhiêu một cái form rồi chồng
cái nút là search
cái bút Nếu Út hay sốt như này thì mấy
em không cần phải có cái nút Bá Tân đêm
nữa mà mày ông chỉ cần bấm enter là nó
sẽ là tự động sắp microphone khá tiện
Tôi sẽ đặt tên em à đây Tìm kiếm đúng ạ
như này à
em có cái này nhập cái gì đó nên tờ này
thì nó sẽ đẩy lên thành cái địa chỉ tìm
kiếm bằng cái gì đỏ như này ok không ạ
Nếu không thấy là tôi đưa nhập bất cứ
cái gì thì nó vẫn sẽ hiển thị tất cả bài
đăng thực là thế không tốt đúng ạ Thôi
tôi cần là ví dụ là gõ F1 thì nó sẽ chỉ
ra những cái bài có tiêu đề có tiêu đề
chứa cái từ mà tôi đã tìm kiếm nó ngoác
cái đoạn này tức là mình cần phải làm gì
đó là mình cần lấy cái tìm kiếm ở trên
thanh địa chỉ này về sau đó thì mình sẽ
lách soundforge cái tiêu đề where were
tựa đề thuộc cái mà mình đã truyền lên
trên huyện chỉ đóng ngoặc a cho tôi sẽ
là đô la tìm kiếm đi
bằng
đôla get đúng không ạ Tìm kiếm
sau đó thì mình sẽ away tiêu đề
like mà ông nhớ lại Ạ phần trăm phần
trăm
Tìm kiếm đợi Tức là sao nghĩa là tiêu đề
có chứa cái chữ mà mình có tìm kiếm đúng
đấy Bây giờ tôi thử xóa thôi à Bây giờ
tôi thường gõ chữ f 1 được đấy
eater Ra đúng ạ Gọi F2 đấy không ra bài
nào về chưa thế ổn thôi chứ đây nó sẽ có
những điểm nữa đó là nếu giờ sự toán mới
và các trang web như này có sẽ bị báo
lỗi là cái biến Tìm kiếm của tôi đang
nói
vì nó không hề có nó không hề tồn tại
đến nhiên rồi vì tôi đã tìm kiếm đâu ông
ạ mới vào trang web vì đâu có tìm kiếm
Ừ thì đoạn này mình phải làm như thế nào
Em đang dạy quen mà về sau sẽ cho các
bạn làm quen dần dần từng từng từ khóa
tiếng Anh một số đó về sau toàn bộ bằng
tiếng anh
như thế à
cho mình mình sẽ phải kiểm tra là nếu mà
có tìm kiếm thì mình mình lấy nó về đúng
không ạ thì mình sẽ lại ít em Tại tôi sẽ
có cái hàm này để mấy ông kiểm tra xem
mà nó có thì ah Nếu có Và nếu không
Mình sẽ kiểm tra nếu có này reset rồi
Nếu có đôi loa ghét Tìm kiếm nếu nếu nó
có
thì mình sẽ lấy cái đôla tìm kiếm về như
này
mô
tả lại trang này nếu lại thấy cái lỗi
nữa lỗi này Nếu phải để ý kỹ lỗi nhá lỗi
nên để hiển thị ra để cho lập trình viên
mình nhìn nhưng mà lỗi này thì chị ra để
mà mày ông có khỏi tôi đâu nhá Đấy
Ừ Cái lỗi này là gì Nó bảo không Không
tìm thấy cái biến biến Tìm kiếm ở dòng
21 đúng lại là dòng này tất cả chỉ là
cái biến tìm kiếm này nó không có đúng
rồi vì mình có tìm kiếm đâu mà có biến
Tìm kiếm đúng không ạ thì
mình sẽ mình sẽ làm đó là mình một là
ông
khi tách nó ra thế hai câu truy vấn như
thế này
thế này à
ở
ngã trường hợp ngược lại này
thì cầu truy vấn của ông sẽ không có
whey như thế này
vào như này thôi nghĩa là nếu có tìm
kiếm thì mình sẽ lấy cái tìm kiếm về này
và I work phải tìm kiếm ông ạ Còn nếu
không thì ông sẽ lấy tất đồng lại đây
một cách mà ông có thể áp dụng theo cách
chơi khác như tôi nghĩa tôi sẽ dậy đến
mức cơ bản này thôi
à à
ạ Và ở đây và đây nhá vị giả sử là bây
giờ ông Nghiệp ấy một ẩn ok Nó ra được
rồi đó ngọn nhưng nhiều người khó chịu
có nhiều người khó chịu về cái vụ là à
em muốn hiển thị lại những cái mà mình
đã tìm kiếm ở đây không ạ người dùng
quên mất là người dùng đã nhập cái gì để
nhận thế người dùng muốn thi lại cái
mình đã tìm kiếm rồi đây mình sẽ có ba
lô ở đây là EXO đôla Tìm kiếm được ạ
đó thì nó sẽ hiển thị ra những người như
tôi vừa phải có nói đó là Nếu giả sử lúc
đầu ông không tìm kiếm gì đó lại lỗi lại
bảo lỗi ở đây là không tìm thấy biến Tìm
kiếm đúng ạ Cái đoạn này mình lại phải
làm gì mi lại phải vào đây là Minh lại
phải pp bpa ở đây như này ít reset I
số đo Tìm kiếm rồi ạ
và đây sẽ là papain này bóng ít như thế
này
Em nói như này
ib1 cách
Ừ nhưng mà người mà ông thấy bạn này nó
sẽ rất là dài không hiểu là kiểm tra
Thôi trông cốt chống phải xấu đúng ạ Tôi
có một mẹo này khiến mì uống cà phê
nhanh hơn này
ở đây tôi sẽ tôi sẽ cho lúc đâu người
dùng Tìm kiếm chúc đầu
Ừ tôi sẽ cho đôla Tìm kiếm ở đây luôn
bằng nghỉ chỗ rộng ngay
anh luôn
ạ sau đó thì
ừ ừ
ạ sau đó đi sao
Ừ tôi sẽ có luôn đoạn này xuống dưới như
thế này à
à à
em không thấy à nó chạy ngon không gần
đây gì nữa đúng ạ Tại sao cái đoạn này
vẫn chạy ngon cho tủ rõ là tôi không thể
tìm kiếm tôi tìm kiếm thử nhé
vẫn ngon này Xóa các tìm kiếm đi
vẫn ngon này Tại sao thì tôi sẽ giải
thích mấy ông đoạn này Đầu tiên là tôi
cho mặc định nó bằng chuỗi rỗng Đông ạ
Nếu không thấy đều không ạ sau đó thì
nếu mà có phải tìm kiếm của tôi để hệ gì
thì tôi lấy cái tìm kiếm mới về truyền
nó vào trong cái chỗ giọng đấy đúng ạ
sau đó tôi queo nó hiện nay có xảy ra 2
trường hợp trừ một là nó không có tìm
kiếm thì chỗ đấy là rỗng mà tiêu đề like
theo cái chỗ rõ đấy
Ê mấy ông sẽ nghĩ nó lỗi không ạ Không
tìm cái gì cả không Nếu mà like theo
kiểu là
à à
Ừ nếu mà ông nhớ thì like theo
như thế này hoa cả thận thêm một cái nữa
có thêm chục cái nữa thì nó nó vẫn sẽ
trả về mụn gọi dậy kết quả của vì like
như thế này tất cả không nó thỏa mãn nó
luôn thỏa mãn bởi phần trăm như dõi từng
nói nó Thái cho một hoặc nhiều ký tự
không ký tự nào được like hết đông ạ Thế
Lai như này tất cả like đúng kiểu như
này không có gì cả nó sẽ trả về mọi
người quả không lỗi
mà biến Tìm kiếm ở đây vì nó luôn khai
báo trên này nên là mình sẽ không mở bị
báo lỗi ạ bên Tìm kiếm không không tồn
tại không ạ tôi cách rút gọn của tôi
thường hay là em giờ không biết được mấy
ông có thấy khó hiểu quá không
còn không người Méo phải ít nhau rồi như
vừa nãy đồng mạng thế tôi chỉ nếu hai
cách đấy
Ừ rồi bây giờ vừa rồi làm xong tính năng
về tìm kiếm
anh không biết mày không đủ thoáng chưa
Nhưng bây giờ sẽ dạy thêm về tính năng
nào
ở phân tra
phải làm tìm kiếm trước mới làm để phân
tranh tại sao vì hai thằng nó thương lại
đi kèm với nhau và có liên quan đến nhau
ạ bây giờ sự mấy ông thầy đang có Bye
bye bài đăng với ông thấy ít thì ra
chẳng cần phải phân trang thì cứ mỗi 3
bài mày không ạ Nhưng mà nếu bây giờ sự
danh đương nhiên là về sau
ở phía sau có nhìn bài đăng
anh 2 triệu 7 đang đứng như trang tin
tức trang Dân Trí ạ thì khi ở mới vào
trang web này cái tê nó cơ chế là nó cái
file pp a nhớ nhớ kỹ thuật này nhé ppp ở
cơ chế nào là nó phải chạy Xong hết nó
mới hiển thị ra cái trang web của mì ông
Hải ra mấy ông thấy vào một vài cái
trang web thấy nó loát nữa lâu rồi nó
trắng trắng tinh rất là lâu rồi đúng
phát nó hiển thị ra một loạt đóng ngoặc
trắng tinh và tận mười mấy giờ thì em ạ
rất là lúc đấy file file pp đó phân xử
lý phải render ra htl xong hết đã dầu
mới nở một loạt ạ
à à
ý thì cái trải nghiệm người dùng công
nghệ tốt bây giờ là sử như tôi nói nó là
một triệu bài đăng ở hạn ông phải chạy
vòng lặp in đủ 1 triệu 7 đang ở đây đã
rồi mới trả về cho người dùng thì
Vì sao thầy hiệu trưởng thi Cai
Ừ cái trải nghiệm người dùng chứ sao nó
không hề thích cái điều đấy đúng ạ với
dùng đâu cần để xem hết một triệu về ăn
cùng một lúc đó đúng quá người dùng chỉ
cần xem những cái bài đăng mới nhất phải
vân vân chẳng hạn thế thì bây giờ cách
làm như thế nào đó là bây giờ mình sẽ
phân cha mình sẽ bây giờ đang Mới có 3
bài đăng đây là mình sẽ phân trang giả
sửa mỗi mỗi mỗi trang một bài đang trở
lại hoặc cả hai bài
12 bài 10
12 bài 1 trang thì sẽ ra bở Để câu hỏi
cho mấy ông
em hỏi mấy câu đơn giản nhé em xem lại
ông giỏi toán không à Tôi đang có 3 bài
đúng không ạ Bà bài đăng
mà tôi muốn một trang chứa 2 bài thì
Anh có bao nhiêu xã à
anh hỏi Toán tập 1 khi nướng trả lời tôi
câu này
hệ thống kê trả lời 3 cửa
ở một trang rưỡi cũng đúng 1 chén rưỡi
323 ok
ạ bây giờ mấy ông những cái ông mà trả
lời 22 trang có vẻ đúng rồi đúng không ạ
Cứ cho đúng đi mấy ông trả lời tôi Tại
sao nó ra ngay sao ạ
Mà tại sao nó lại thành ai chưa
à à
Ê mấy ông lấy ra đâu ra con số 2
Em đừng nghĩ ra đúng không
em làm tròn 1,5 đến 2 cái ông lấy 1,5 ở
đó là
sơ đồ ngoại 3 chia 2 làm tròn lên đúng
không ạ Ok bạn kia vừa nói được cái công
thức phải có công thức luôn công thức để
ra được số trang không ạ nghĩa làm chỉ
là
mình sẽ
Ừ cái 37 đang nó sẽ là tổng số 7 đang
đóng lại sau đó thì mình sẽ chia cho số
bài thơ Người Cha
và hai bài không ạ rồi làm tròn lên
không ạ thì sẽ thành ra được tổng số
trang ah
Ừ thì bây giờ câu truy vấn để mà mình là
ý được tổng số hải đăng thì mình sẽ
A1 làm mấy ông sẽ nghĩ là sẽ cao đúng
không ạ nhưng mà không Không cần phải
làm vụ sẽ thích cao mình mình sẽ có thể
đếm được cái
ở Hà Nội chắc mình cũng phải làm sao đây
ca đấy à
mô hình sự selecao để đếm số bài đăng
thỏa mãn đã để mà ra được số trang đúng
không ạ
những như sau
thì mình sẽ là selects
câu
về tôi sẽ có
đợi tôi tí
khi tôi viết lên trên này đi tôi sẽ viết
lên trên này à s clous
ở
lại là số trang nhà
bạn cernex cao sao này
for tin tức này à
ạ sau đó đi Đương nhiên mình sẽ có kết
quả bằng chạy câu lệnh này thôi
là kết quả số trang đi
và lấy cái này mình sẽ cần là lấy cái
giá trị cao sao này ra thì mình
Ừ
thì mình sẽ có câu truy vấn à đây thôi
tôi sẽ gọi là câu truy vấn này
Ừ vậy thì tôi phải nghĩ là cái tên này
đó sẽ dễ cho mấy ông kiểu xem cái này nó
đỡ choáng đi
ê ê
chung
kết quả số trang lần hay đi bằng
mcquarrie
fake tôi hết
Tôi đã không nghĩ được cái tên nào tiếng
Việt để cho mấy ông có phải dễ hình dung
cái này
anh Bởi vì cái này làm ảnh
mạnh đây mạng số trang này
và đây sẽ là kết quả số trang
và đây mới số trang này à nhầm nhầm đây
không phải số trang quên quên quên tôi
bị nhao nhao nhao số bài đăng mới đúng
số tin tức
Việt Nam lấy tổng số tin tức mà không ạ
số tin tức này
E Ngại quá ngại quá
số tin tức này à
à à
ấn
vào đây xù tin tức sẽ bằng
kết quả chính thức tại hàm cao sao
bao nhiêu này để lấy ra được số xổ số
tint
Khi mà mình sẽ cho là số
tin tức trên một trang bằng hai nào ạ
ca nhạc đâu vậy
ừ ừ
ờ
sau đó đi mình sẽ ra số trang nhưng mà
vợ vừa nãy các bạn nó tách là số tin tức
chia cho số tin tức
trên một trang và làm tròn lên đúng
không ạ làm tròn lên mình sẽ có Hàn là
hàm sale như này là hàm trần nhà để làm
tròn Nó lên đấy mình thử DC cái số trang
để các bạn xem nhé đây đi tất cả à tức
là nó sẽ nắp nó sẽ in ra kết quả bằng
nắp tại dòng này luôn các bạn xem em
xin lỗi
à À đây đây nhầm nhầm nhầm cái này kết
nối này đây thì chị nhầm nhầm
a a nhằm Bye bye quên PD ê
ở đây nó giả hay đúng ạ Tới tất cả hai
tranh
à Mình nhầm nhầm DD là nghèo hư rồi quên
quên quên đấy chứ
Bye bye nha Đang nhé lắp tại cái đấy
Ừ ok Các bạn thấy cha là hai đúng rồi
đúng không ạ Nếu mà cái hai này chả tác
dụng gì cảm vì bây giờ nó vẫn chưa ngắt
trang ngọn Các bạn thấy nó vẫn đang hiển
thị ra 36 37 đang mà đóng ạ thế là bây
giờ để lắp
bây giờ mình sẽ Limit
là số tin tức trên một chai như này thì
nó sẽ nhắn này
ở đó có bạn thấy lúc nó chưa chín tạ 89
này Cái bài thứ 10 nó nhẹ sang trang thứ
hai ở Đông ạ Thế bây giờ làm thế nào nhẹ
sao cha thứ 2 đóng ngoặc thì mình sẽ cần
thường là tôi sẽ in ra một cái đường
Linh ở đây bấm vào nó sẽ nhiều thời gian
hay Bấm vào nó nhảy sáng giao một chẳng
ạ thì mình sẽ có ở cuối cái thê bồ thì
sẽ có một cái á vòng lặp vậy mà
Đây đây rõ ra là chỗ Trang là hai nhá sẽ
có phòng họp ở in ra từ một đến hai từ 1
cho đến để số trang từ ngọn thì sẽ vòng
là for cũng được TP là mình là pho này
đâu lai rai bằng 1 bắt đầu từ một này
đôi y đền cái số trang này
và đôi cộng cộng này
các
clip pp này
À
mà đây mình sẽ có thể A ở đây
Tại sao phải thấy ai thì tôi sẽ nói sau
đây sẽ là tìm nào số tra nhé à
ở đó thì mày không thấy à bây giờ bấm mà
Em bấm vào thì nó sẽ nhảy sang trang 1
và tháng 2 đúng ạ
em đứng nhân bé Ông thấy là bây giờ nó
vẫn đang ở trang trang một thôi ông ạ
bởi vì sao thì mình cần bấm vào đây nó
sẽ nhảy đến một cái gì đó không ạ Con sẽ
đây tôi thường nó sẽ cho họ chấm trang
bằng như này cho nó kèm theo đôla y nhà
à
có phải lại sao Này bấm vào này nó sẽ
nhìn sang trang 2 này bấm vào nó nhưng
sẽ nhảy sẽ trang 10 ạ Hiện tại ông thấy
tôi bấm vào trang hay nó vẫn là vẫn thế
chả gì thay đổi Tại sao Bởi vì bởi vì
cốt của mình chỗ này nó chưa hề lấy cái
số trang trên 2 địa chỉ lại về đối ngoại
ở cốt này chưa hề lấy số trang trên này
bị chị về nhớ lại tính tiếp bây giờ lạnh
hỏi mới uống tiếp nhé
anh
[âm nhạc]
hỏi lại tiếp này
ờ ờ trang 1
Ừ thôi Hiển thị mấy 15A
à à
ở trong một Nội
ở
trang 1 hiển thị 13 năm
32 Bài ok trang hay hiển thị mấy bà đó
bộ phim yếu ở 2 bài đúng không Ok
Ba Tháng Hai của tôi thì mày đâu
A1
hãy kể một bài văn
ừ ừ
Ừ cái này rẽ mấy ông cha giỏi toán rồi
bố rơi rồi chắc sẽ giải quyết được bài
toán này Bây giờ giả sử tôi Giả sử tôi
lại đi Tôi có 15 mô trang của tôi chứa
tận 37 đăng ký
Ờ thì đầu tiên à Có mấy cha ơi
U17 đăng một trang chửi 3 bài thì có
tổng cộng bao nhiêu năm OK bốn chàng
không ạ Ok mày không trả lời 44 tra
hết trang 1 của tôi hiển thị màu mấy lắm
đi theo một hiển thị 13
anh
vẫn là ba Ok trang hai hiệp định này
Cho tôi thời gian béo trả lời kia tôi
chẳng biết nó trả lời câu thứ bao nhiêu
đấy
cái chat rồi nó không bị delay 30 giây
nữa
có câu Hãy trang hay hiển thị mấy loại
vẫn Ba thôi không ạ rồi Ông kia trả lời
luôn 331 kìa không ạ
chẳng hay hiển thị 33 trang 3 thì như
ông kia vừa nói cũng hiểu đi 3 trang 4
thì Thị Như ông kia nói đó là một bài
không ạ và tại sao tại sao nó ra là con
số một này cái Chỉ đơn giản đơn giản là
mình sẽ với ông dạy bảo là lấy 10 - 3 -
3 - 33 Nó còn 1 thôi mà đúng ạ Nhớ công
thức tính nó không phải như thế cứ tính
của cái số số bài
một
số bài còn lại
thì nó sẽ là công thức là mười ạ 10 này
tổng số bài
tôi
- cái cái số gì đúng không ạ tổng số ba
đây ông ạ - Cái số gì để ra có số 1
Ừ đúng ạ
và chính xác à nó chỉ còn - cái nó phải
bỏ qua bao nhiêu bài mê mấy ông phải nói
là nó phải bỏ qua bao nhiêu bài đúng rồi
bạn kia ra công thức Đúng rồi đấy nó là
một số bài trên một trang
nhân với ba nó không ạ Cái ba đấy rất là
gì là số trang - 1
ở đó
Khi say sẽ đạp bỏ qua bằng con số như
thế này
thi công thức nó sẽ như này
I know Phương Linh ở đúng rồi đó là tổng
bác ái tổng số bài trừ đi số bài trên
một trang
mỹ nhân với số trang hiện tại và số
trang hiện tại
- 1 đây là bỏ qua bỏ qua bao nhiêu bài
Ừ cái 10 bài đăng này bạn chất là nó nó
bỏ qua mày hợp mấy ông phải xem nữa là
để bỏ qua không bài Bỏ qua 3 bài đầu
đây là bỏ qua sáu hoài đầu
bà đây Bỏ qua chín vài đầu
đúng ạ
vụ tai nạn ở đây Cái này nó không Tôi
không biết Nó cũng có tính toán ấy không
Nhưng mà thực ơi ông chỉ cần biết được
cái này lần đầu tiên khi mà học lập
trình về sau mình có thể lo dụng Mấy ông
không cần phải nghĩ nhiều về nó mấy nữa
nhưng công thức nó là như thế này đúng ạ
Nó bỏ qua bao nhiêu bài không ạ
xe tải Thì bây giờ mình có công thức đầu
tiên thì mình sẽ lấy
mình sẽ lấy số trang hiện tại về đúng ạ
Mình sẽ là
thời trang
bằng đôla gas sang
đây lấy trang hiện tại về Đông ạ sau đó
mình làm gì
mình lấy tổng số bài chưa ạ Lấy chồng số
bài rồi số 7 chương 1 trang này rồi thì
bây giờ mình sẽ làm công thức bỏ qua
thôi bỏ qua
bằng
sổ tin tức này
-
số kiến thức chứa một trang nhân với số
trang ah
em
ở đâu nhân bé trai
- 1A
[âm nhạc]
Ừ thế là xong à
ở đây sẽ bỏ quá Mà mình ở đây mình sẽ có
thêm offset
là bỏ qua nha Là sao em mình sẽ chạy thử
máy ông
Ừ hình như có gì đó Sai sai để xem lại
phát trang một bỏ qua
à à đôi đâu thì hình như tôi ghi công
thức khi nhưng khi bị sai rồi xin lỗi
xin lỗi xin lỗi thì gọi nha
3000 đoạn này tôi nhận đấy bỏ qua không
phải công thức này Ờ
số bài trên một trang nhân với số trang
hiện tại
Ừ ừ Chị ngại thôi bỏ cái xuống thức đi
tôi nhầm
Ở nhà quanh hậu Á
à à
có ai đây Đúng rồi Đúng rồi ngủ quá đi
Ừ Ông ơi Không cần phải lấy tổng số bài
chủ đi nữa về chỉ là số liên tục nhân
với số trang hiện tại rồi - 1 thôi ok
tại mày không thấy ngon chưa đó Thế làm
được cái xin Trang rồi nhưng mà Anh nên
nhớ là mình luôn kiểm tra đó là khi giờ
xóa này đi nó lại nổi này không ạ Nó lỗi
rồi kìa lúc đầu vào thì làm gì có trang
nào đúng ạ thì mình sẽ phải Quý Hưng
luôn lúc đầu vào nếu mà không truyền
trang lên thì Trang nó sẽ mặc định là
bằng mút Đông ạ thì mình sẽ là thì lấy
sẽ có là
ở lại ít cái này thôi copy cái đoạn này
đổi Đây là Trang Thôi
vào đây sẽ eo
trang bằng 1
Còn nếu ông ấy Ông muốn kiểu không muốn
dùng eo thì ra hạn chế dung theo ít
nhiều mình có thể quý gốc luôn lúc đầu
cha bằng một sau đó như thế này cũng
được
nó vẫn như nhau đúng
xe tải không lỗi gì cả
anh ạ
à Nhưng cái này lại còn sinh thêm một
vấn đề cuối sinh thêm vấn đề cuối nó như
sau là sử tôi tìm kiếm
ờ ờ
có thể tội tôi bây giờ mấy méo hình Dũng
được cái việc à phân tranh này rồi nha
mẹ tôi đổi số liên tức trên một tra là
một đi
Ừ thôi mấy ông sẽ thấy à Có 3 bài nên có
thành 3 trang Ok đúng ạ Bây giờ tôi sẽ
ghi F1 tester ở đây
Ừ hết một enter đúng nhỉ
Ừ đúng rồi F1 enter
Ừ đúng rồi em một em tôi ở đây mấy ông
sẽ thấy các em
Ồ không tôi chưa dậy mấy ông để hỏi chấm
hỏi chấm đâu cơ bản thôi
à em một em tờ đây mấy ông thấy đang lỗi
còn gì số trang rồi Không đúng đấy trước
một bài thôi Chỉ có một bài có chữ em
một thôi đúng ạ bởi vì bạn này ở đoạn sẽ
cao này tôi không đúng nó sẽ cao này tôi
phải kết hợp với cả tìm kiếm mày nữa
không ạ kết hợp để tìm kiếm hai nữa nên
tôi sẽ
Ừ tôi sẽ vứt cái đoạn mà
đi tìm kiếm lên trên tạo vất cài đặt tìm
kiếm lên trên này
cho tôi sẽ Where giống hết cái đoạn nó
rồi như thế này
cả hai loại đều quay tìm kiếm này không
ạ một hàng để lấy số tin tức để mà lấy
ra được số trang nữa đâu ạ
à à
ở đó tôi tải lại sao này nó ra đúng một
bài đăng ra đúng một trang thôi Ok đúng
rồi đúng không ạ nhưng mà bây giờ giả sử
thôi
chờ
đợi tí cái xem có hai cái bài đăng thì
tốt
ở Hà Nội Hà Nội 33 có hai bài đang ấy
thì Đức Hà Nội Hà Nội này inter này nếu
thấy có hai và năng nhớ Hà Nội đúng
không ạ
anh bởi sao cho tìm kiếm chữ Hà Nội thì
nó sẽ chỉ có bài đăng tiêu đây Hà Nội
em nếu bây giờ tôi ấn vào sàn thứ hai
ở đâu thấy gì xảy ra không ạ nó lại
thành 3 Hải Đăng tại sao nó lại thành ra
ngoài đăng bởi vì chỉ đơn giản là mấy
ông thấy để ý trên anh nghệ sĩ đã nó
không hề truyền theo cái mình đã tìm
kiếm đúng ạ
nó không truyền theo cái mình đã tìm
kiếm mà khi bấm vào đường link ở đây nó
sẽ chỉ truyền theo cái mẫu số trang thôi
mà không truyền theo cái mình đã tìm
kiếm
ở đâu thế
ở Hà Nội đấy
cái tơ này đó như thế này lại mất đúng
không ạ Thế được cách để mình giải quyết
bài toán ở đây đó là
cho mình khi mình à nhảy Sang trang khác
mình cũng phải truyền theo cái mình đã
tìm kiếm thế thôi mình sẽ có và đây này
tìm kiếm bằng
sô-cô-la tìm kiếm đó như này
Vì vậy tôi tả lại tra phát nữa này đầu
tiên không có bạn vẫn 3 bài có phải đúng
Hà Nội này enter này tôi bấm nhảy sang
trang 2 đó nó sẽ kèm theo cả tìm kiếm và
nhảy sang trang 2 về chưa đó Đây là toàn
bộ toàn bộ về
ờ ờ phân tranh kết hợp với các tính kiếm
à à
à Mà ông kia đang bàn về vấn đề gì về
sôi nổi về 13 này dễ cho mày hoang Smart
rồi sẽ bỏ qua đi
ừ ừ
Ừ ok à
đề thi
a b bây giờ sẽ nói nốt về mùng tí khách
khùng à
sơ đồ mạng
để để cho mấy ông có vẻ hào hứng phút
cuối thì cái vụ hack mà tôi tôi nói mấy
ông đó là nếu mấy ông đăng cái trang
trang web của mấy ông lên Nếu không
phòng chống về khách cùng gì cả thì hoàn
toàn thằng những cái bạn khác vào phá
thì thì mấy bạn ấy sẽ có thể là nhập
những cái kiểu là gọi lại SQL injection
a khái niệm nó FBI injections thức là
sao injection tất cả tiêm nhiễm tiêm mã
độc sợ tiêm vào tiền thử không tốt và
không phải tìm bác Xin lỗi nhé à
A và
phạm và cái từ spo tất cả thì nó lợi
dụng lỗ hổng của Apple để mặc tiêm vào
để mà làm gì đó là hack thì chắc chắn
nào để làm những cái thứ mà kiểu không
tốt giống như là cậu đây mà lấy thông
tin các bạn hoặc là điều hướng các bạn
Sang trang khác vân vân Bây giờ tôi sẽ
làm thử đề môn trong mấy ông Đúng rồi
tôi sẽ tự hack trang web của tôi sẽ
thắng thật đi
em giả sử bây giờ nếu để ý kĩ là bây giờ
giả sử người dùng vào
cái thằng hacker ấy thì nó sẽ cơ chế
hack của nó sẽ làm như sau đó sẽ kiểu bà
vào để ý kĩ là người dùng sẽ đang in ra
cái gì ở trên trang này thì người dùng
Đăng ký email tiêu đề không ạ
khi người dùng đăng ký để tựa đề gì nó
sẽ thật nhiều nó sẽ chỉ cố hack mà cái
loạn tiêu đề để mà để mà khi mà người
khác và nhìn người tiêu đây này nó sẽ bị
lỗi nó sẽ kiểu hiển thị ra một cái gì đó
nhạy cảm Và thậm chí cho nó lấy đực
Cookie của các bạn mà như mình đã nói
quốc kia nó là nó là kiểu phiên đăng
nhập các bạn
mở rộng Tóc trên Facebook nó là yên đăng
nhập các bạn nên thả và lấy khuy các bạn
thì có nhờ các bạn mất nick kiểu thế
Ừ Thì
ờ ờ
ạ bây giờ sữa tươi ẩn thêm bài viết này
Tôi chỉ quan tâm tiêu đề rồi nhá Mấy cái
nội dung có thử tôi để chống được không
sao đúng ạ
về tôi sẽ có thể cho thể H1 ngay cái lô
trở lại
đóng thẻ một này cần thêm này
3000 thất bại gì không ạ bấm sao trang
này
em có nếu thế là thêm chữ Hello thành
thể H1 rõ to không ạ Tức là sao nếu
thoái cơ mà thử hack một cái đơn giản
đây này nó truyền vào HTML bình thường
mà nó in ra được đúng HTML như thế thì
hoàn toàn nó có thể đi ra được cái gì nó
nó không Không phải Ý là cái ảnh gì đó
Nhưng cảm nữa mà nó thường ai chèn thêm
ra Suite vào để mà điều hướng các bạn
hoặc là như mình vừa nói là lấy được
quốc kỳ các bạn Nhưng mà thường có thể
điều hướng bạn xanh trong web Mở đó là
sửa để Script này Windows chấm location
thức hàng ngày ông sang trang web khác
này Atlas này
bằng cái gì đó
e Băng đúng nhỉ Nó không ngờ lắm Windows
location the spirit không nhớ lắm đâu
Hà Nội dung cái này mấy đó tôi khách
Hùng gì đâu
ừ ừ
Em thử đi thử thử thì biết không ạ
ở
bảng http
google.com trở lại
đóng thẻ Swift về
chấm phẩy cho chắc
bí ẩn Hanna
he he lỗi lỗi bởi sao mai là nó hỗ trợ à
Nó là kiểu mình đang có nháy nên nó bị
lỗi như thế này
Ừ
thì mình chỉ dẫn thả là đổi cái nháy lại
Thành nhái đút vào xong
à à
em vừa rồi mình dùng nháy đơn thì bị lỗi
thì bây giờ mình đổi thành ấy Lúc thì
Quanh ai
xem thêm
anh không nổi nữa đâu ạ Ok Bây giờ mình
sẽ vào lại này sang bài này
ở đó nó bị điều hướng sao Google mất rồi
ông ạ
ở
[âm nhạc]
đấy mà ông sẽ thấy ạ Đây Rồi mới chỉ một
ví dụ thôi
Ừ nó thì điều hướng làm sao mà người
trang web nguy hiểm Bảo gà mua khi vào
da spa được chạy như thế hoàn toàn thể
lấy Lúc kia của ông địa đẩy có kia ông
sang server của nó vẫn loạn luân đấy à
ở đây from theo kiểu form mà nhập vào
cái gì mà Mấy ông không không hề kiểm
tra nó thì mà Mấy ông kiểu cứ hiển thị
ra đúng cái mà người dùng đã nhập người
dùng nhập ra rất nhiều Ngày thứ nghị cả
là nó sẽ hiển thị ra Đông ạ Đấy Vì sao
tôi sẽ hướng dẫn hơn mấy ông cả khách
được phải thanh tìm kiếm các thư thứ nữa
mày ông sẽ có đầy thứ để mà biết hack
thùng cá thôi hư không thể đem đi áp
dụng đâu mà tôi tôi bảo tôi không biết
về hack nhá tôi không học thế hạnh nhé
nhưng mà tôi học lập trình cho tôi biết
được là những cái chỗ nào nó có thể gây
được lỗ hổng bảo mật thì nên là du lịch
Hải Phòng trong nó đúng không ạ ạ
Ừ đúng rồi một lạng
bình thường là bây giờ cũng nên làm
những cái là duyệt nhưng mà những cái
đăng ký hai mấy cái đăng bài đăng bài
luôn vẫn phải chờ hết rồi chứ là đăng ký
hai cái thự thứ gì đó nữa là sự giống
nhau Hồi trước Việt Thảo cũng từng làm
hay sao đấy Đó là hack cái nhạc của tui
vậy
âm nhạc của tui tự nhiên có cái lỗi lỗi
vớ vẩn đấy Nó kiểu in cái tên người dùng
nhập gì cũng không in ra xảy ra hồi đấy
ở lớp lên hack kịch bài You tim của khối
đấy khiến cho mà hồi đấy Cái phết rồi
đấy ạ
Ừ cái cái cái thấy dạy nói chung là cái
đấy cái giải thưởng giải thưởng ạ
đợt nào ấy đợt Chia sẻ mã code mã code
mà nhiều người dùng để sẽ được lên cái
bảng vinh danh của nhạc của tui là 8 giờ
tối hôm đấy là công bố kết quả rồi thì
cái mã đấy rồi chia sẻ trong Nuti Nuti
thành ra là kẹo cái tài khoản của việt
Hảo đấy được lên nằm trong tốp mười sau
đó thì
ờ ờ ông Việt Hạo ông vào thứ Tư đổi tên
hàng kiểu giá quýt vừa rồi xong rồi chèn
thêm Plus là hai cực bài trừ tim tự
nhiên thế mà vẫn được thôi cùng thì ạ
bất kỳ ai vào cái trang bảng xếp hạng
đấy Đều hiển thị lên hai cực bài Điều
tim mà lúc 7 giờ tối 2 7 giờ tối 1 tiếng
trước khi công bố đi qua thành ra nhạc
của tôi phải tạm đóng đóng cây trang web
đấy và công bố cách đấy phải 4 tiếng đó
ừ ừ
Ừ từ trang web ở trang web nó rất là dễ
dễ để cốt nhiều người thường ai cốt giữa
rối Không kèm với một phương món gì cả
cái búa cái đương nhiên là sẽ nó sẽ cậu
chắc chắn không còn mình lỗi vớ vẩn thế
nữa Nhưng mà thường trang web kiểu ngang
như thế nhiều người cốt của p thuần cái
gì đó nhanh ngay thôi đấy và công nhận
thức ra cái đấy rất là tệ khi mà kiểu
xe máy mà ông thì thảo thì ông ấy à Làm
kẹo như thế để mà vui vui thôi
về chưa ông ấy làm căng thì bất kỳ ai mà
truy cập vào trang web bởi vì gần đến
rồi công bố mày thằng là ai cũng vào để
xem nữa trúng họ
ừ ừ
anh không nhận ra mấy ông đẹp quá lại
khó chịu thật nhưng cũng biết rằng gần
gần đến giờ công bế quả rồi tình yêu còn
thương và pha
đấy nhưng mà đấy chỉ là một cái ví dụ
sát lại cậu
thực hiện thực tế mà các bạn thấy à
à Không vẫn có nhiều ông vẫn còn bị dính
đâu ạ nhưng mà không Tôi khuyên béo được
gọi cho dạy nha
bộ phim Quốc nó tích hợp sẵn rất nhiều
cái ạ thư viện hay các hàm có thử rồi
thực ra về sau tôi chỉ ông Chỉ cần một
hàm mày không trả được một cái từ một
cách tương đối rồi những nhưng mà Phương
Quốc thì đúng là chuẩn chị thôi con chặn
cho ông không phải về mỗi mấy cái cậu
Phố bẩn vừa rồi mà còn chặn nữa ông
những cái về
tư duy lôgic lỗ hổng bảo mật để tư duy
lôgic nó còn rất nhiều nữa cơ
anh về sau tôi chỉ muốn nhiều cái lắm Về
Sau hôm bảo vệ đoán Lúc mà tôi ném đá
không mấy ông cậu bé Ông thấy là cái đồ
án của ông có thể dễ bị hack hay dễ bị
phá như thế nào ạ
khi dùng phải xss đi lấy được có key
hiện tại đang có trên máy
Em ở Việt Nam bình thường thế nào cậu
chế em ạ Ông nhảy vào nhà thằng khác đấy
phá cậu Thế ông luôn đi tù
nó không có cơ chế cậu bức Bon Ti lắm
Cho dù là nhiều công ty thì nó có hạn
Chính xác cái thật đấy nhưng mà không
phải là rất là sự thật kiểu nó vẫn không
ngon ngon như bên nước ngoài
Ừ đúng rồi các bạn sẽ phải dùng ra
spiders Hòa giọng như mình đã từng nói
thì phải hoa ghép vào mắt em nữa kiểm
tra xử lộ nhập vào các từ thứ trước khi
nhập vào lưu lại trong B chúng mày kiểu
các bạn Nhập vào bất cứ thứ gì lưu lại
trong b để không được không ạ
vừa rồi Các bạn thấy là rõ là mình đăng
bài bài đăng mình còn không nhập tiêu đề
không nhập ảnh vẫn còn thành công mà
đúng thì ta thế không được
à à
Ờ Ờ mình không rõ vì cái cốc kỳ theo cơ
chế cho Đốm main lắm
anh bởi vì mình không tìm hiểu bên đấy
lắm
Ừ nhưng mà chắc chắn là nó có thể lấy
được kì các bạn bằng có thể là không lấy
được cô ky có đô main nhưng mà có nhiều
cách mà sự có rất nhiều cách thì mình
lấy
anh nói chung là một khi ở mấy ông vào
một cái trang của bị hack rồi là kiểu gì
mà béo bị lộ rất nhiều cái và bị ảnh
hưởng nếu cậu nó tự động Download cái gì
đó Bây giờ ra trình duyệt nó còn hỗ trợ
chặn vụ nó vẫn khỏi lại vụ download
Ừ nếu mà vẫn có cách để thông qua đấy
cách câu nói chung hợp tìm mẹ lắm mấy
ông
áo phông cưới Hải Phòng trước đúng không
ạ
Ừ ok
vừa rồi mình nhận nói qua một loạt tất
cả kiến thức của buổi hôm nay các bạn
còn thắc mắc gì thì chắc là bình luận
thôi không Không thì mình sẽ ra bài tập
nhé Thứ 7 cho mình sẽ chữa bài I Swear
sau không
à à
đi cấy Chào bạn nhé
anh ta